do you remember the pain oh all of it
yeah I sort of moved my legs and I said
oh that one
that one's really messed up it's gonna
be a problem Jeremy broke 15 of the
bones in his entire body this image
shows the blood-soaked snow at the scene
of where his body was crushed by the
seven ton snow plow are there any
obvious injuries oh my God yes Jeremy's
neighbor Rich Kovach is the voice you
hear in the Frantic 9-1-1 call I looked
at his head it appeared to me to be
cracked wide open and I could see white
I don't know if that was his skull but
that's what I thought I saw is this new
yeah yeah I just got upright yesterday
and you guys
Diane Sawyer interview airing tonight on
ABC was shot 10 weeks after the accident
from inside Jeremy's La home
[Music]
The Avengers star was far from wallowing
singing from his walker and surrounded
by family including his mom who never
left his side in the hospital your mom
read to she's reading Stephen King some
like horror thing
but just wants to like read like she's
reading Dr Seuss to me like you know
it happened to be what I was reading at
the time
I just wanted him to hear my voice
Jeremy is set to make his first public
appearance Tuesday at the LA premiere of
his Disney plus series Renovations where
he helps repurpose decommissioned
vehicles to help communities in need ET
has an exclusive first look at his
episode in India shot well before the
accident you out now to the just
released cause of death of rapper Coolio
as I walk through the valley of the
shadow of death E.T can confirm the
59-year-old died last September from an
accidental overdose of fentanyl heroin
and methamphetamines after it was
initially thought to be a heart attack
just continuous compressions is going to
give him the best chance okay according
to the corner asthma also played a role
in his sudden passing
[Music]